Let's say that you've had repeated
fights with your wife about how domestic
duties are going to be arranged among
around mealtime and you believe me.
You're going to have those fights and so
and so.
What's happening is that mealtimes are
unpleasant because there's a war for
power going on in the kitchen.
Right?
And so then you think one day while
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Note that and you're going to do an
archaeological investigation and find
out just what the hell is going on.
And so you start unpacking the fact that
mealtimes are not pleasant.
And so what's in that little thing that
you're unpacking that package?
Well,
the entire power dynamic between men and
women in the modern world is inside that
dispute.
And you might find that part of the
reason that your wife is upset about the
way that mealtimes are arranged.
Because because her grand mother was
beat by her grandfather and that's
playing a role in.
It played a role in determining her
unconscious expectations.
And that's pathologizing one of the day
to day rituals in the house.
And if you're going to unpack that,
you're going to have to unpack all of
that into the.
You take a little monster and you
decompose it and you find out it's a
hydrates.
Got 50 heads and then you have to work
through every single one of those.
It's really,
really difficult and so it's a container
that contains everything.
But the thing is if you unpack it
successfully,
let's say,
and you deal with it,
you negotiate a consensus,
then all of a sudden you get,
you get paced,
say around your meal times,
which is a major accomplishment man,
because you have to eat three times a
day and it's the center of the household
and all of that.
So,
but the thing is is that often when
you're especially in the context of a of
an intimate relationship,
things will emerge that produced
discontinuity.
And the question is,
what should your attitude towards that
discontinuity be?
While you can punish the person for
manifesting that discontinuity,
that's the tyrannical aspect,
or you can let it take the whole thing
apart and that will happen.
I mean,
that's often how relationships and is
that a discontinuity emerges and people
get into it and things go sideways so
badly that the whole relationship
descends into chaos and people bail out
of it.
So.
So it's no wonder that people want to
ignore it and it's also no wonder that
they want to tyrannized it.
It's like,
quit bothering me with that.
Well,
possibly,
but probably not.
And also if my attitude towards you is
quit bothering me with that,
your attitude towards me when I have the
same sort of problem in reverse,
it's going to be exactly the same.
And so we're not going to get anywhere
with it.